mechanics I always puzzle a little bit
over why a mechanic's was called
mechanics because we look at motion
right in all these other kinds of
context to unit extension one and this
is just more of it so what's the
difference okay so let's begin by say
we'll look to universal right what's
even to unit motion what does it include
it includes straight lines good straight
line so just one dimension the dimension
okay and then within that one dimension
we think about three particular
quantities threes you get what are the
three quantities you start with okay I
if you can't see that'll be a fourth one
we generally say with Aerts which is
displacement you get displacement and
then we think about how displacement
changes which is velocity right and then
we think about how velocity changes
which is acceleration cool and that's it
that is the entirety of tune immersion
okay so I put that in a box right now
when we move to three in emotion I
should say extension one but you get the
idea right what three in emotion is is
two emotion but then we add on a couple
of different things right what do we add
to tune emotion that makes it extension
one okay so I heard two different things
which are both really good first I heard
our simple harmonic motion right so we
look at a particular kind of
straight-line motion because simple
harmonic is still up down up down still
a straight line right but when we add
its oscillation right and despite it
being a very simple idea
it leads to all of these different
unusual things that you can understand
like amplitude frequency phase shift but
okay now as well as oscillation we also
add what was the other thing another
dimension it's exactly right
we add one dimension so we're no longer
just a straight line up and down by or
left-right we have two D situations
right what were the 2 D situations we
looked at clearly project that and since
you've got necks in a Y in there right
that was where we had to think about
resolution of horizontal vertical
velocities and so on and so on okay so
there you go that's how you go from two
unit to three unit so now we do this
three demotion right what do you add to
it to get to Mechanics for Univision now
there's a few different ways to put this
okay but I think really there is just
one thing that we really add and then we
look at different example of it I think
the one thing that we add is mass that's
it that is the one key difference
between I think about this right
displacement velocity acceleration what
would the units that we were thinking of
over here
those displacement might be something
like meters times me when you're going
to velocity acceleration then you add in
time right so you got meters
you've got per second per second square
okay so when you add in mass of sugar or
sugar many meters per seconds seconds
forth when you added mass you're getting
kilograms right now when you combine
these guys with these guys you get a
whole bunch of different sort of
iterations and versions of those which
we're going to dig into a little more
okay so that's that's the context right
now let me tell you what are some topics
under this so I'm there three okay first
we need to understand Newton's laws
these laws now some of you guys know
Newton's laws back to front already
which is great
it will clue you in to getting the right
answer but you have to be careful
because in extension to we're doing more
than just using these levels okay which
is where physics is emphasized right
we need to understand how where they
combat and what's the mass underneath
them and why do they work okay so Newton
law Newton's laws is where we begin
after that the next thing is the idea of
resisted motion okay so this comes into
play when you think about things that
are heavy or things that are light right
and when their motion their movements
right when it's being stopped when
influenced by something which being
resistant okay so we talked about
different media like if you're in a
medium on air or if you a medium like
mud
okay that's resisting the motion you're
trying to do okay your third and last
one is circular motion oops circular
motion okay
now even though circular motion in a
classic example of arm how you get
circular motion is when you are when you
have what's called the conical pendulum
I'm understand the sacrum which moves
like this okay and it makes sort of like
a curved shape up here even though that
looks like it's 3d right what you're
really interested in is actually just
that 2d circle so it doesn't add another
dimension really so what you've got
underneath circular motion as some
points are number one they're conical
pendulum okay so it's not just moving
back and forth and back and forth it's
moving round and round okay and then you
have one more example circulation called
a banked track and we'll get to that in
due time okay so now you have a bit of a
picture for how all fits together okay
as you can see because for you motion is
three demotion and other stuff right
you've really got to come back to this
right I'll give you an example
acceleration this cut tends to be those
problematic the most complex okay we
write acceleration but that's not the
only way that we write it right what
other ways can we describe acceleration
you could write it as X double dot but
of course the two dots what do they
actually mean they mean differentiate
with respect to time right so a more
descriptive way of saying X double dot
would be
d squared X DT square okay so there's
three ways but we learn more
what were the other ways we learn V DV
DX right we learnt that guy and there
was one more one more
dr DX of half v square which directly
comes out of this one right you just
look at this I don't know how you feel
when you look at that list again right
there's some real opportunity for
confusion here if you don't get what
this is right and we're just going to
add more complexity to it okay
so right out the gate one of my big tips
for mastering this topic is to go back
and master these kinds of questions in
extension one okay if they give you any
trouble then we can work on those
because if you're strongly in there it's
kind of a bit of a arm a silly thing to
try and move on to these which treat
that as a given